[Musique]
grosse fête de la du sport à la Réunion
et et la fête de la de la de la Réunion
tout cour et pour l'athlétise plus
particulièrement de grosses performances
je pense que 2015 à la Réunion ça va
être des jeux comme on aura pas encore
vu j'aimerais dire convivial mais dans
la boxe il y a pas de convivialité donc
bataille on va batailler pour réussir
nos jeux dans la boxe et j'espère que
tous les athlètes entendront mon message
batailler pour que la réunion soit en
l'air je suis un olympien ça sera ma
petite olympiade dans l'île de l'océan
Indien et croyez-moi vous les verrez ils
seront tous là ils auront tous envie de
se battre nous c'est donner du rêve et
faire en sorte que les personnes aillent
au bout
[Musique]
d'elle-même
à 274 jours des jeux des î nous avons
faire un point avec nos partenaires avec
les ligues comités et avec la presse sur
l'organisation des Jeux des îles donc
actuellement je pense que tout est calé
au niveau des appels d'offres au niveau
de l'organisation et je pense que on
monte en puissance on a un commissaire
des jeux on a des actions qui sont
menées et il était nécessaire
aujourd'hui de faire un point sur un top
sponsor qui a été choisi mais également
sur le la mascot des jeux qui est
tibayun qui est le le fils de bayun de
98 aujourd'hui c'est la mascotte je dis
que ce sont des éléments fédérateurs
dans le cadre d'une manifestation
également on a l'ouverture d'un site
ensuite je pense qu'on passera par
d'autres moyens pour communiquer sur les
états d'avancement de l'organisation des
Jeux par des communiqués de presse ou
bien par des interviews ou bien par une
manifestation sportive qui va mettre
plus en relation l'organisation on doit
voir ces jeux non pas comme une
compétition entre uniquement sportif
mais comme une grande fête populaire
sportive tout le monde doit être
concerné par ces jeux parce que derrière
là il y a la la rencontre des gens de
venant de différentes horizon qu'il est
nécessaire d'apprendre à connaître pour
faire vraiment ce lien la Réunion est
une terre de champion la Réunion est une
terre d'accueil on sait qu'on sait
accueillir donc il faudra que l'ensemble
de la population quel que soit l'endroit
où il se situe se soit se sent concerné
par ce jeu